Hey, it's great to see you,
um.
CEO of a company called Model, we build
AI infrastructure.
Serverless inference is one of the many things we offer.
Um, we, uh, power some really
cool customers like Suno, Lovable,
and many others,
uh, doing things like inference, training,
code sandboxes,
and a lot of other stuff.
So let's, uh, let's walk through what Model does
and, um,
how it works.
Uh, we, uh,
we're based in New York.
Been doing this for about 4 years. I
started the company about 2021.
Modal is an infrastructure platform
that makes it easy for developers to build and scale
AI applications.
So, when you're building these AI
applications, you need infrastructure.
So you need a place to run all these
applications, right? And as it turns out, when you're
building these things, working with large scale models,
working with GPUs, uh, a lot of
existing infrastructure doesn't really cut
it. So you're trying to deploy things
using Kubernetes, EC2,
Docker,
it's kind of a nightmare, uh, and it really drains
developer productivity, and then you have a lot of these
challenges around
not, you know, managing.
Predictable demand and particularly with inference, you need
to be able to scale up and down very, very fast and
manage the utilizations and GPUs are expensive
and GPU capacity is limited.
So you have all these issues around
infrastructure management and that's what model solves.
So we run tens of thousands of GPUs all
over the world. We manage that for you.
We're a big customer of AWS.
Very happy with that.
Um,
And, and we, we basically started a
company with this sort of
thesis that today's infrastructure is
not cut for, for
AI applications.
And in particular, when you go deep on it, it's, you
look at Kubernetes in, in the past, and
sorry to pick on Kubernetes, but it's, it's a lot of traditional
infrastructure as a whole. It's built for a kind of a
different era of
uh compute. It's sort of a crud,
you know, like kind of a steady
demand, CPU based applications.
It's pretty cheap. But then you go to
AI land and now you're running very expensive
GPUs and
it, it, it poses a lot of challenges
for how we deploy and scale applications.
And so
Some of those applications is just a high cost,
some of them is scaling and working with these large
models.
Some of them are kind of new things, like
how do you programmatically execute
uh a code that you don't trust necessarily.
It may be code that comes from an LLM,
so you need a sandbox primitives. And then of course,
there's training,
how do you do all of the storage of all of this underneath,
uh, big batch jobs,
all these things.
Uh, so, so we basically built our own stack.
So we started at the ground level,
we built our own container runtime,
we built our own file system,
uh, and then we built a bunch of storage primitives.
And the reason we did that was that enables
us to have this amazing developer experience
that lets us iterate extremely fast and
build this really, really offer like an amazing
developer experience. Uh, you're trying to
find something that sparks joy.
When you're working with model,
and I'll show you some code in a second.
Uh, you can get, you can take code from your
laptop and run it in the cloud in less than
a second, uh, on GPUs, state
of the art B-200s.
Um, and what's cool about model
is
we power so many different use cases and
so many different,
uh, parts of the sort of AI journey,
right? Like we do,
we focus on machine learning developers, uh,
primarily, but we do inference
training,
we even have notebooks. So you can do bass jobs,
you can run code execution,
we're building many more things.
So Modal, sort of an end to end platform
for all, a lot of different things AI.
We have a lot of different customers,
some may be recognizable,
maybe you heard of Mena,
uh, but we also have some really cool sort of
new AI companies. I mentioned Lovable,
they're using us
for, uh, all the uh code execution.
Um,
we have some
companies like
Cognition and Decagon using us for LMs,
Suno, AI generated music, they run all
their inference on Modal.
Uh, so, so we're on some pretty large scale.
And it's all over the place. We're also actually doing a lot of biotech
too. So we have a lot of customers using us
for scanning millions of
compounds and doing, you know, advanced protein
folding on, on GPU or sequence
alignment and things like that. We have people
using us for
weather forecasting. We have people using us for curing
cancer. Uh, we have people using us for
audio transcriptions, text to speech, speech
to texts, and a lot of applications and
audio. Uh, but, but really
sort of any modality. LM of course, is
a cor cornerstone to
modern AI.
And how does it work? So we're not an AI API.
We don't have like
necessarily a set of models. You can run any model
on model.
Some people run
their own proprietary models,
some people deploy an open source model.
So it's not like you're limited to a set of models,
you can really run anything here.
Uh, we take any code. We take
your code, we take a container, and we make
it run a modal, and we manage all the scaling.
And so,
the general way people do this is to write
a little bit of Python that basically takes functions
and turn them into serverless functions.
So you can think of modal.
Yeah, here's a quote from, and
I actually I think this is a really cool example.
It's a robotics example, so they obviously have
like very low latency demand, like we're basically
using model to control a robotic arm.
Incredibly cool application.
Um, and, and so one way to
think about modal
is that it's, um,
It's, it's two parts. One is a Python
SDK where you can
write a little bit of code that defines
the functions you want to run and scale in the cloud.
And underneath
where the infrastructure substrate that basically
scales that, manages all the capacity,
so you don't have to think about scaling. If you need 1000
GPUs, we can give you 1000 GPUs within
sometimes seconds. So we have these
crazy large scale, very bursty jobs,
sometimes, you know, big bath shops or infer, very
unpredictable inference.
We can scale up and down extremely well.
And, and how does, so let's talk about the first step. Let's
talk about the,
the Python SDK.
Here's a little bit of an example.
And hopefully,
you're familiar with, you know, Python and how it works.
Uh, here's an example of like how you can deploy
a function in modal.
You start with like a little bit of Python,
you add a decorator,
oh sorry, you import modal, of course, first.
The key thing is really here, you put this decorator
on any function,
that turns this function into serverless
uh function that runs in modal.
Uh, we run a lot of stuff on AWS, but also
other clouds,
many neo clouds and, and the big hyperscales.
And in particular here, as you can see,
uh, we run this on an L40S,
which is one of Nvidia's latest GPUs.
Very good for imprints, especially for smaller models.
Uh, and then, you know, we load the model,
just, you know, using a hugging face, transformers.
Um, and that's it.
Zero infrastructure needed. When you get started with
model, you just write a little bit of code,
you run modal run or modal deploy,
that turns it into an app, it runs in the cloud,
and that's it.
Underneath,
well, here's the one kind of beauty of this.
Put in the words of our, one of our favorite
customers, Suno.
So they run, as I said,
music, AI
generated music in the cloud.
Uh, and, and what they love is like,
they're a small team, they can focus on what they're really, really
good at, which is to build models
and build consumer applications,
and we take care of all the infrastructure underneath
with a few lines of Python, they get all this done.
And it's all in code.
You know,
0 Yamel, 0 configuration.
No one likes to write YAL or docket files, actually.
Uh, so, so you write like a few lines of Python and
it just, you know, turn, we can also take an
existing container and just move it into Modal,
but the, the main way people use Modal
is just through the Python SDK.
Uh, and underneath, how does it work? So
we built our own container on time, we built our own
file system,
we built our own container image builder, we built our orchestrator,
built our own scheduler,
all of this stuff, right? Like we make it, you know, the
cloud development just work,
uh, which is a very hard problem, you
know, and hats off to AWS for doing something
similar, like they built the EC2 and all these things.
And we use some of those,
uh, but these are very hard engineering problems, and we built
this underlying infrastructure stack we felt because
we felt like
the infrastructure for AI just wasn't there.
So some of the cool stuff we can do is we can, we
can snapshot CPU memory, we can also snapshot
GPU memory, we can restore that. So
we have incredibly fast container cold
start. We can start GPU models
and start running inference calls in less
than 1 2nd, even with large models like 10s of gigabytes.
Uh, and part of that is like all the deep investments
we made in the infrastructure below.
Uh, and we also manage all the scale.
So like I said,
we manage tens of thousands of GPUs
all over the world, some of,
a lot of them in AWS.
It's all usage-based.
So you only pay for the time the
code is actually running,
which is very nice with inference because you have very unpredictable
demand. And especially with inference, when you're scaling
up and down,
you don't want to go out and make a reservation of like
kind of a rectangle, like you want to
just pay for what you're using.
Maybe your app goes viral and you need 1000 GPUs
tomorrow, maybe while you're sleeping.
Uh, we handle that. We scale it up and
manage that scale for you.
And when there's no traffic, we scale down to 0
and it costs you nothing.
And you can also deploy CPUs, uh, CPU
functions. And so
this is a lot of the work underneath.
As you can see, we're on a lot of different AWS regions.
This is one example of A10Gs how we managed
that. This is a lot of under the hood.
But the point is like,
we take care of all of that complexity for you.
You don't have to think about it.
Under the hood,
all this complexity about like getting GPU capacity
and managing that and scaling up and down.
Don't think about it, we got it.
Um,
And we also have a very fancy internal
observability dashboard. You
can see,
this is one screenshot, but you can, you know,
see latencies and you can
see GPU temperature and number of containers.
Uh, and this is something a lot of our developers really like, the
machine learning engineers. They love seeing and having
full control,
taking stack traces, looking at the logs,
and really understanding what are my GPUs
doing at any point in time. How do I maximize.
Um, and so,
Uh, so when you deploy the model,
you can just log into your dashboard and see all these
things for all your apps that are running and see
exactly how much you're paying at any point in time.
Um,
and, and part of how, what, how we think
about the future is
we take all this demand and just
manage all that complexity for you, and by
doing that, we can run it way more efficiently
than anyone else can do
because traditionally, at least in the last few years, the only
way to get GPU access has been
to go make reservations.
I don't think that makes sense because then everyone has to make
a reservation for the peak,
but by like taking all that work, all, all
these workloads and combining them, we
can manage that.
Utilization way more efficiently.
So a lot of people actually,
even though our
$1 per GPU hour,
sometimes it's higher,
but the net cost might
actually be lower moving to modal because you're only
paying when the GPSs are actually running. And we can
do that because we invested a lot in driving
GPU efficiently,
GPU
utilization,
because we have this multi-tenancy.
Um
And, and yeah, so you see some amazing
developer love. I really think that the developer
experience is what sets Modal apart.
People really comment on like, you can just
write some, a few lines of code,
get it out in production, you don't have to worry. So
it's really time to market that I think people
come to us initially for.
They want to have their very complex models, maybe
they're training or
doing fine tuning. They want to scale up,
you know, big bass shops or run.
Code sandboxes, and all you have to
do is pip install model and get started,
and people really love this developer experience. The
one thing if you talk to our customers, it's,
you know, it's a
We just handle all of that underneath, all the infrastructure
and you just have to write like a few lines of Python.
Uh, here's another example.
You, you, we,
we help sub stacks scale out to hundreds
of GPUs, like big batch jobs.
Uh, we have many other customers that scale out to thousands
of GPUs,
uh, maybe around, we had a customer the other
day who processed 3000
years of audio in a few
days, uh, doing some advanced,
uh, I don't know what they're doing actually.
It's very cool.
And the love is there.
We've been building this for about 4 years. We're obsessed
with building products
that developers really love. I'm
a developer. I've been writing code for
32 years, I believe, something like that.
Um, professionally for 25 years,
uh, we, um,
we really think about how do we make engineers
productive and how do we take away the sort of
boring parts of infras of, of,
of their job,
and which in many, many cases is the
infrastructure, the configuration.
We love infrastructure, so I like building
this stuff.
So we take the, the boring stuff away from
you and we build all the infrastructure for you,
so you don't have to think about it, especially with these AI
applications, they're pretty hard to manage.
Our typical customers tends to be machine learning
engineers. It tends to be people who are building models
or fine tuning,
building quite advanced things, and they really
love that they get this like full control.
We're not trying to take away the power and the
control from customers.
In fact, we're actually enabling them to move
faster and deploy more complex
things, and get the power of, you know, the
scalability in the cloud and, and get
even more GPUs than they previously had.
So it's really about,
you know, making engineers
move faster and, and
scale up at large scale.
And, and, and a lot of what people
do is really like,
again, we're not an AI API we don't have a set
of models. You can run any code or model.
Whatever code you have, if it's a proprietary
model, in the case of
uh Suno, or if it's an open source
model, you can deploy it, we can help you with that.
We have a lot of templates and a lot of examples for how to
get started. Um, and
like I said, it's consumption based,
so you only pay for the time the GPUs
are actually running, which is a really nice feature because
it means with these, you know, unpredictable
scaling demands that you often have doing it in
France, uh, you don't have to pay for the sort
of periods in between when the GPUs
are sitting idle,
because we can run other workloads on those.
So how do you get started?
If you want to check it out, it's very easy.
Go to your terminal,
do PIP install modal,
you can start writing code and running it in the cloud
immediately.
Uh, every user gets $30
a month of free credits.
And if you're a startup, you can actually get up to $50,000
worth of credits, which goes a pretty long way.
That's we have many startups who initially started
at Modal,
many white combinator companies, etc.
started scaling at Modal,
uh, or, or, or doing the prototypes.
Issue with modal and now they're running a very
large scale in production.
So we're there for you when you're building the prototypes.
We, we help you with the developer experience.
We help you move fast.
We also help you scale it up and
run it on thousands of GPUs when you're
ready to put some production workloads.
Um
So thanks a lot. And if you want to reach out
to me, you can follow me on Twitter. I'm Bernhardtson,
you can check out my blog, which is,
sadly, I don't blog as much as I should these
days, uh, but I used to. Uh, or you
can email me. I'm Eric with a K at
Model Model.com.
So we'd love to stay in touch. Any
questions or any thoughts? I don't know if we have time for questions.
Thank you.